pagerank is a measure of the importance
of a web page
but let me immediately correct my own
confusion that i suffered from for some
time until very recently which is that
even though pagerank is used for ranking
pages it's called pagerank after its
effort after its discoverer developer
larry page who is one of the co-founders
along with serge brin of google
so the motivation is that um when you at
least before google when you did a
standard retrieval on a web page using
keyword search and similar kinds of
criteria you'd get back millions of hits
um most of which were really
low quality and you weren't interested
in and with a few useful pages buried in
the millions and the question was uh all
of these documents are indistinguishable
in terms of keyword search and and
textual patterns how do you figure out
which of the important ones and the idea
that
that page came up with was to use the
web structure itself the structure of
the world wide web to identify the
important documents
so we can think of the
uh the whole internet as a graph
where a user is
on a page and we think of a url as a
link to another page as a directed edge
and users are kind of randomly traveling
around in the world wide web they're at
a page they randomly click a link to get
to another page and they keep doing
doing a walk on the web graph and every
once in a while they're going to find
that the thread that they're on is kind
of losing steam where they find
themselves in some kind of a cycle and
they will randomly start over again
at some other page
and we want to argue or
hypothesize that a page is more
important when it's viewed a large
fraction of the time by these random
browsers and random users
so to be formal we're going to take the
entire world wide web trillions of
vertices as a digraph
and
there's going to be an edge from one url
to another from v to w if there's a link
from
uh the page v to
uh the page w or the url w w might not
even be a page it might be a document
which means it doesn't have any links on
it but for the the the real vertices are
the web pages that have links on them
okay that's the model uh and we're gonna
make it into a random walk graph by
saying that if you look at a
url v a vertex v all of the edges out of
it are equally likely it's a simple
model and it might or might not work but
in fact it did work pretty well that is
the
model of the world wide web
as
a random walk graph
so to be more precise the probability of
the edge that goes from v to w
is
one over the out degree of v that is all
of the out degree of v edges leaving
vertex v get equal weight
now to model this aspect that the users
start over again if they get bored or
they get stuck
we can formally add to the digraph a
hypothetical super node
um which and with the property that
there's an edge from the super node to
every other node with equally likelihood
so once you're the super mode then
following an edge is tantamount to
saying pick a random page and start over
again
um
to get to the super node we uh have no
we have edges back from
other nodes in the graph back to the
super node now in the reading we said
that uh we were going to have nodes back
from uh from no terminal nodes that had
no edges out for example a document or
something like that that's actually not
sufficient because uh for the
for the pagerank to work in the
theoretical way that we want it to
because even if there is um no dead
nodes you might be in a clump of nodes
which you can't get out of and you'd
want to be able to and even though none
of them was a dead end because they all
had arrows going out to each other and
so you'd really want a node from an edge
from a clump like that back to the super
node to model starting over there
the simplest way to do it really is to
simply say that there's an edge to the
super node from every vertex so where
wherever you are you can randomly decide
to start over but uh and
paige uh and brynn and their co-authors
in the original paper on page rank uh
suggested that the edge back from a
vertex to the super vertex might get a
special probability it might be
customized as opposed to being
uh equally likely with all of the other
uh edges leading a vertex in fact i
think they decided that it there should
be a 0.15 probability from each vertex
of
jumping at random to the super node
okay um
let's just illustrate this with an
example this is a random walk graph that
we've seen before modeling coin flipping
and when i add the super node there's
this one new uh
vertex super and there's an edge from
the super vertex to every other one of
the vertices in the graph and from each
vertex in the graph there is an edge
going back i've illustrated that with
two-way arrows
so this is really
an arrow with two arrowheads it
represents an arrow in each direction
now in the original paper actually uh
paige didn't talk about a super vertex
instead he talked about
each vertex randomly jumping to another
vertex but that would just get the whole
state diagram completely clogged up with
edges so it's more economical to have
everybody jump to the super vertex
and the super vertex jump back to
everybody
and that
saves a significant number of edges
so
pagerank then is obtained by computing a
stationary distribution for the world
wide web
so s bar is a vector of length trillions
the chord chord the coordinates are
indexed by the web pages
and we want to calculate the stable
distribution and then we simply define
the pagerank of a page is its
its probability of being there in the
stationary distribution the v component
of the stable of the stationary
distribution s
and of course we'll rank v above s when
the probability of being in v
is higher than the probability of being
in w
by the way um
i don't have the latest figures but uh
there were
uh i guess i've heard people have worked
for google say and in some of the
wikipedia articles that it takes a few
weeks for the crawlers to
create a new map of the web
to create the new graph and then it
takes um
some number of hours i think under days
to calculate the stationary distribution
on the graph
doing a lot of parallel computation
so a useful feature about the uh using
the the stationary distribution is that
ways to hack uh the
links in the world wide web to make a
page look important are
will not work very well against page
rank so for example one way to look more
important is to create a lot of nodes
pointing to yourself fake nodes but
that's not going to matter because the
fake notes are not going to have much
weight since they're fake and nobody's
pointing to them so even though a large
number of fake notes
point to you
their cumulative weight is low and
they're not adding a lot to your own
probability
likewise you could try taking links to
important pages
and try to make yourself look important
that way but pagerank won't make you
look important at all if none of those
important nodes are pointing back
so both of these simple-minded ways to
try to look important by manipulating
links won't improve your pagerank
the supernode is playing a technical
role
in making sure that the stationary
uh distribution exists so
um uh it guarantees that there's a
unique stationary distribution as bar by
the way i sometimes use the word stable
and sometimes stationary they're kind of
synonyms um although i think officially
we should stick to the word stationary
distribution
um when as i've mentioned before when a
a digraph is strongly connected that is
a sufficient condition for there to be a
unique stable distribution that's
actually proved in one of the exercises
in the text at the end of the chapter
the supernode mechanism also
ensures something even stronger that
every initial distribution pay converges
to the
uh
stationary distribution to that unique
stationary distribution state precisely
mathematically
if you start off at an arbitrary
distribution of
probabilities of being in different
states p
and you look at what happens to
p after t steps remember that you get by
multiplying the vector p by the matrix
m raised to the power t
and you take the limit as t approaches
infinity that is to say
what distribution do you approach as you
do more and more updates
and it turns out that that limit exists
and it is that stationary distribution
so it doesn't matter where you start
you're going to wind up stable and as a
matter of fact the convergence is rapid
what that means is that you can actually
calculate the stable distribution
reasonably quickly because you don't
need a very large t in order to arrive
at a very good approximation to the
stable distribution
now the actual google
rank uh and ranking is more complicated
than just page rank pagerank was the
original idea that got a lot of
attention and in fact the latest
information from google is that they
think it gets over attention in the uh
today in the modern world by too many
commentators and and people trying to uh
simulate ranking
so the actual rank rules are a closely
held trade secret for google by google
they use text they use location they use
payments because advertisers can pay to
have their search results listed more
prominently
and lots of other criteria that have
evolved over 15 years and they continue
to evolve as people find ways to
manipulate the ranking google revises
its ranking criteria and algorithms but
nevertheless pagerank continues to play
a significant role in the whole story